pour avoir une jolie barbe il faut pas
dépasser 3 semaines généralement 3
semaines c'est bien il faut pas venir
avant 2 semaines isamou de 35 ans et
Barbier professionnel il a débuté ce
métier à 14 ans dans les faubourgs de
Tunis aujourd'hui il travaille dans ce
salon de beauté versailla longue épaisse
de 3 jours où en collier le
professionnel tente de trouver la bonne
formule pour ses clients il faut créer
des formes géométrique par rapport au
visage par rapport à la personalité de
la personne et par rapport à ses envies
certes il y a des barbe plus plus belle
plus fournie que d'autres mais après à
nous de de créer le bonheur pour tout le
monde pour répondre à tout type
d'exigence ISAM a besoin de brosse à
barbe de tondeuse de blaau de serviette
chaude de rasoir et même de fils
polyester pour épiler les pommettes des
outils indispensables pour un travail au
millimètes des fois on enlève un poil et
on peut se retrouver avec un trou juste
en dessous donc il faut bien regarder sa
barbe juste avant de la travailler faut
faut prendre son
temps il faut pas être pressé de de de
de raser de prendre son coupchou son
ciseau son
rasoir il faut sa tondeuse il faut
vraiment prendre son temps une technique
apprécié chaque jour son planning est
bouclé au minimum à 60 % et ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux à venir pousser
les portes du salon il y a quelques mois
j'ai eu un jeune il a à peine 17 ans il
a juste des duvés et sa mère lui a
offert euh un rasage traditionnel
c'était marrant parceon voit pas
vraiment le poil mais il voulait tester
donc il en a qui commen très tôt comm
très tard final un passage par le rasoir
d'AM va vous coûter entre 20 et 50 € le
prix pour adér une mode quiè du poil de
la bête depuis